they can be tiny or they can be larger
than life but one thing these replicas
have in common they look just like the
real thing here is the fascinating world
of models just like alright where can
you see the Eiffel Tower Mont
saint-michel and the Arc de Triomphe all
within a few steps of each other
France of course well miniature France
[Music]
located two hours outside of Paris
miniature France is a theme park made in
the image of real friends but at one
30th of the original size the park is 12
acres in size
and features a hundred and seventeen
different monuments miniature France was
built by a team of 50 model makers and
landscape architects ensuring that each
model is an exact replica of its logic
counterpart to make this hybrid city
come to life there are animated trains
cause and planes that move around the
region and while you might not have time
to see all the real friends has to offer
in one day you can make your way around
this park in one afternoon although your
photos might not be the scale
[Music]
panties is just an installation from the
war it was a linear path ordinary do not
know the equation neurocircuitry spirit
was the problem he has accelerated we
are projected straight admissions
manager such dynamic load model to
conquer
[Music]
deep in the suburbs of Moscow in a town
called Nova selkie Sergei and his
comrades tirelessly work on a pretty
unique hobby
through years of experimenting and
prototyping they've taught themselves
how to build life-size tanks out of a
garage all in the name of celebrating
Russian history must eat Wacka Wacka
Sneha mi soo my little beauty Network
shaggy it is an immovable spent on
actually admitted deduction Jeremiah ran
a solution
seriously daughter the cotillion
especially why you could not anxious why
I'm taking improv even me pardon us we
should reduce control subject UNK
concerns of what you say foreign spoon
get a system for surveys no prevail in
Anubis to duplicate aroma college this
painting agronomic Alistair book he
should be no spirit to dismiss openness
producing the most a good MS idea that
the bureau service is seen in the tank
stay busy metropolis machinima Boise
panzerkampfwagen again it's just not one
of the machine you have to be tanker is
when consolidated
I did smoke would not be respect on of
the diesel 10's mr. gromek a little
skeptical cultural very discouraged not
as mr. Wallach move a person as a team
with the Omaha team because I'd
promotional Chicago good shuttles to Jos
country inside its design
[Music]
can you smell this international wired
Muslim because I assumed it included a
to mushroom in a global economy so I can
alleviate them the probability a vehicle
at the refuge solutions is machinery
Jerry's fault Jerry's the both
technically at the Dublin return through
pretentious Castro
a lot of the work is quite repetitive
the pleats took about two months to do
probably did those eyes ten times even
the texture of the skin their graceful
dancing which I wanted to portray that's
the whole goal is to make them feel like
they're gonna swim away
[Music]
I'm Steven Kessler also known as tusk
I'm a large-scale wildlife sculptor I
found sculpture a little later in life
in my late 30s moving from one career to
the other especially into the art world
that's totally scary and foolish thing
to do I don't think I had an option
after I started sculpting I think my
life was going to be no matter what I
did
sculpture as a whole has inspired me I
mean it's 24-hour thing for me sleep
just gets in the way almost when I'm out
doing day-to-day things not being here
that's always running through my head I
don't know if I personally call myself a
daydreamer but I could probably be
labeled one
[Music]
there is definitely a calming with clay
I usually work 12 hours for three days
straight being able to realize what I
want in it quickly it just seems like it
works together with how I process I've
been involved with making three
life-sized giraffes 40-foot whale shark
for manta rays and we're working on this
30 foot iguana behind me that back
whales took roughly nine months the
inspiration to do these pieces for the
aquarium was because Utah is a
landlocked state there's a limited
number of people that you see these in
real life anyways to be able to be in
the same room feel the size of it
hopefully there's an energy to it and
hopefully inspire conservation packs
because of it
if someone says oh I can't sculpt this
I'd have you tried by it you know you
never know what's gonna happen
open the box of clay see what's in it
you know there might be a humpback whale
in the future
[Music]
aleppo citadel the ancient city of
Palmyra and the Norris of Hamas all
ancient heritage sites and all destroyed
in the Syrian war it's a loss not only
to Syrians but to the entire world and
these refugee artists are finding their
own way to rebuild what has been lost
Patman notice to me that was sort of the
whole there's our my whole different
sizes for men and none of Solaria enough
sinhala Roy yeah enough Salib NY legit
mr. Haku medallion ashore
they have been using found materials
such as wood clay and even kabob skewers
to make scale models of these historical
landmarks mr. Ellison Saraswathi Murphy
hey I said mafia is she
their work is a way to preserve Syrian
history and educate the world about the
conflict dr. Melissa de da de Lara me
know well Azzam dr. harem Surya
yeah no Haram Jabara Kadima you know
Adama Rasul Allah hi we are with
Mohammed are later a thermal aphasia I
can tell the real have our service a
Ferrari fraternity the moral United
[Music]
States Robin was - way we talk when
hosen value for ahem a syllable and
surely occur on even Bosley Nevada
cursive melody a the artists say that by
making this work they are drawing
attention and giving what they can to
the people of Syria
and I'll admit that Megan Tamara
sooravali Nocturne ACMA animo didn't
bail attorney highly animated normal
here
[Music]